what I'd like to share with you this
evening is some of my latest work for
National Geographic about sharks tour as
we say where I come from in
Massachusetts shox over the last two
years I've worked on four separate
projects four separate stories about the
top predatory species of sharks on
planet earth and the idea was this was
done in hopes by running him as Greg
said by running these stories
consecutively in the magazine we ran
three of them one more upcoming the idea
was to sort of give these animals
somewhat of a makeover I think the the
hope at least my hope was to to change
or replace fear with respect because
nobody respects sharks more than I do
believe me nobody respects sharks more
than me but what I also wanted to do
tonight in addition to showing some of
this brand new work or the latest work
was to include some earlier work that
might give a little context to these
news stories because for me sharks have
been sort of this lifelong pursuit
something that has fascinated me for a
very long time and I wanted to sort of
give context to how I arrived at these
news stories by looking at some of the
the early stuff I actually saw my very
first shark in the wild back in 1982 it
was off the coast of Rhode Island in
very murky waters out there I was about
20 years old at the time and I had been
invited to join a group of marine
biologists that were doing their own
sort of little private trips out there
and they were led by a scientist named
Wes Pratt who had built his own shark
cage sort of this little chicken wire
cage that he made and he would go
offshore and put a little Chum in the
water and hope to see mostly blue sharks
so I can remember standing in that cage
just below the surface on sort of a
mildly rough day and waiting for hours
just staring out into the gloom hoping
to see a shark I was just about ready to
give up hope when at about 4 o'clock
that afternoon that first shark appeared
it was a female blue shark about 6 feet
long
and the instant I saw her I was both
instantly amazed and sort of hypnotized
stunned by that beautiful blue color
that they have on their back sort of
glowed in that afternoon light without
really thinking about it I opened the
door of the shark cage and swim outside
because the shark wasn't coming close
enough to the cage and I really wanted
to get close and to make pictures
the scientists later told me that I was
the first person to ever swim outside
the cage but I just had to get close I
needed to be up close to this animal now
my heart was racing in those moments
there was a real mix of emotions on one
hand I was thinking you know what do I
do if she comes at me what do I do if
she tries to bite me and on the other
hand I was just so thrilled to finally
be you know out there in the middle of
the ocean with this gorgeous animal
she moved elegantly through the water
sort of meandering her way around coming
pretty close at times and clearly aware
of my presence but really paid me little
attention it was if she was on her own
mission some ancient journey that didn't
include me and I was just a momentary
distraction after a few minutes she sort
of just moved away from me and and swam
toward the boat and I watched her glide
into the shadows and then disappear into
that late daylight she was gone and once
again I found myself sort of just
drifting alone in that emerald green sea
feeling like I was waking up for a drink
from a dream and and wondering if it was
all really true if this had really
happened this first encounter
now the first encounter that I had with
a wild shark as I said happened when I
was about 20 years old that was four
years after I became a certified scuba
diver my my very first seat card right
here was about 16 years old kind of
stunning actually how little I've
changed since since I was 16 but but I
became a diver because I had this deep
desire to explore the ocean and to
photograph animals like sharks that was
a big reason why I wanted to become a
diver and you know until I had that
first experience with the blue shark
these animals seemed
like mythical creatures to me like a
unicorn you know I'd read about them but
until you actually are in their presence
it doesn't really seem real so the first
experience with the blue shark you know
had me completely hooked no pun intended
I really knew that I I needed more that
I wanted more there was something about
these animals that that captivated me
that fascinated me and I knew I had to
get back out into the sea as often as I
could you know just brief moments even
with these animals they're difficult to
photograph and it takes a lot to get out
there and see them but I knew that if I
could just get out there a little bit
more maybe I could satisfy that desire I
think part of what attracted me to these
animals was the fact that many species
of sharks of course are powerful
predators big apex predators and there's
an attraction to that I wanted to
experience that for myself up close for
those of you who have dived with sharks
I think you can attest to the fact that
there is this seductive blend of grace
and power that sort of exudes from these
animals it's palpable when you're when
you're in their presence but as a
photographer I also became somewhat
obsessed with sharks from a visual
perspective you know throughout millions
of years Nature has sculpted these
animals to be perfect for life in the
sea these very hydrodynamic bodies for
me they became a subject that I just
wanted to constantly photograph and
always wanted to try to showcase I
wanted to get that ultimate shark photo
to really show their beautiful shape and
form and there's many different types of
sharks so it was a it was a lofty goal
about a decade after I made that very
first blue shark picture I had that very
first encounter 1982 in the mid 90s I
made this photo of another blue shark
near my home in New England and I went
into the water
that particular day wanting to make a
picture that really showed and
accentuated their exquisite contours you
know this was a an animal that truly has
been sculpted and has that beautiful
long slender body and those beautiful
big pectoral fins that help it glide
through the ocean it was a bright sunny
day but in order to make that photograph
I selected a very high aperture to turn
the the background sort of black and to
lit the dorsal side of the animals it
passed below me that little red thing
streaming off the dorsal fin is actually
a parasitic copepod a little pelagic
hitchhiker that was adding a dash of red
color to the otherwise blue background
so as my work evolved and continued with
shark's eye I continued to focus on
these forms and shapes looking at
individual body parts you know the the
dorsal fin of a of a lemon shark in this
case adorned with a trio of remoras
these parasite fish or the giant unusual
head of a of a great hammerhead shark
very bizarre looking animal that almost
looks prehistoric but scientists
actually tell us that these are animals
that are more evolved than other species
of sharks because they're their nostrils
have separated out to either side of
that giant hammerhead and they sort of
have stereoscopic smell they're a little
bit of a one-upmanship in the game of
evolution in the ocean I also sort of
develop this fascination with with shark
tails
you know most photographers that girls
want to photograph the mouth or the
front end of the shark but I became
really attracted sort of hypnotized by
the tails many species like this tiger
shark or Makos and great whites which
we'll see shortly have these exquisite
tails and and a really powerful tail and
you know now with digital photography I
had the luxury of being able to shoot
more frames not relegated to 36 on a
roll of film so I could experiment more
and take these kinds of pictures and so
to satisfy this weird obsession I have
with with shark tails but one of the
other things that was important to me
one of the things that I tried to do
with photography was to make pictures
that allowed us or allowed animals like
sharks to sort of display their
exceptional biology you know sharks have
evolved over hundreds of millions of
years they haven't really changed in
hundreds of millions of years because
they're perfect for their life in the
ocean but I wanted to make images that
would allow let's say the text and a
story to talk about some of these
features like their eyes you know most
sharks have eyes that are exceptionally
good in dark water you know we know that
a cat can see really good in dark light
but sharks can see twice as good
as a cat can and these animals have skin
that is made up of millions of tiny
little teeth they're called dermal
denticles but they're very hydrodynamic
and you know help the animal efficiently
swim through the ocean and I don't if
you can see in this photo but they've
also evolved these little dots on their
nose on their snout there these are
called ampullae of Lorenzini and they're
a nerve ending that allows the shark to
detect electrical impulses in the water
like the beating heart of a fish so if
they're hunting in very murky water or
eyesight doesn't work they can use those
ampullae of Lorenzini to home in on
their prey so just amazing predators and
being able to make pictures that allow
you know the text to talk about that was
important and in terms of evolution i
also wanted to show that you know a
shark is not as a shark as a shark that
they've all developed and evolved
morphologically for the environment that
they happen to inhabit and even with
things like their teeth they're not all
the same at all this is a sand tiger
shark that i photographed in japan and
you can see those sort of long slender
teeth that the sand tiger has which are
very different than a regular tiger
shark this is a tiger shark and you can
see those sort of triangular serrated
teeth here that the tiger shark has
which are used for chomping into their
prey which is often things like sea
turtles sorry for the sea turtle fans
and the audience but but you know
they're very different so you know
making these kinds of pictures helped I
think readers and helped you know give
some some dimension to these animals and
also wanted a photograph species like
the whale shark which doesn't have teeth
at all or the teeth that it has are very
very small this is a a plankton feeder
not a predatory shark but the biggest
fish in the ocean this is one that I
photographed in Mexico and was sort of
entranced by this living wreath of bait
fish that was encircling its head as I
was free diving alongside of it there
that day in these coastal waters that
were very green actually saw my very
first whale shark in Western Australia
back in 1995 giant animal and I can
remember we were using spotter planes to
go out and sort of find them and then
when they found one they would radio to
the boat and tell us where it was and
we'd position ourselves way in front of
it and
I would slip into the water and just
sort of wait there snorkeling for this
animal that materialized out of the blue
and you know it was like swimming next
to a dinosaur that's the the closest
thing I could imagine just silently
emerges and then sort of fades off into
the gloom but you know despite my own
personal fascination and love of sharks
I realized that these are animals that
for many people are something to fear
something that they don't like you know
there's still the old adage that the
only good shark is a dead shark and
sharks have been portrayed as demons
something that must be killed you know
this has certainly been true in modern
times of course with films like Jaws
it's even though jaws sort of demonized
sharks I have to say I do love that film
but for other reasons but but you know
we were sort of demonizing and
villainizing these animals long before
Jaws the book or the movie came out this
is a painting that was done by John
Singleton Copley in 1778 it's called
Watson and the shark and it shows this
you know monster like shark about to eat
this woman that's fallen in the ocean
and all these people are being
terrorized and you know I think for a
very long time sharks have been
portrayed as these sort of shadowy
one-dimensional monsters that don't have
any depth to them they're just out there
waiting to eat us the second we put our
toe in the ocean and the reality of
course is that although they are
predators and have the potential to do
harm to humans we're definitely not on
the menu and these are actually rather
complex animal sciences only beginning
to fully understand them but they're
very very complex creatures and they
play a vital role in the health of the
ocean so as I worked on new stories for
the magazine I wanted to produce images
that would allow people to see sharks
and new ways you know in new light and
help change some of these misconceptions
that exist whenever possible I wanted to
make images that showed sharks within
their environment because what we've
learned over time is that healthy
ecosystems in the ocean depend on
healthy populations of predators
particularly animals like sharks this is
an image that I made of a black tip reef
shark in a place called millennial at
Millennium at all out in the
the central South Pacific one of these
places that because of its remoteness
has remained largely unspoiled and it's
a very Sharky place the biomass of
predators like sharks is very high there
and there's a direct correlation between
the the number of sharks and the health
of the the coral reefs this is science
that enric's all and is pristine C's
team who I think might be here tonight
have sort of proven and I saw it not
only in these places but in other places
you know I was on an assignment for the
magazine a number of years ago in New
Zealand doing a story on marine reserves
and I was in Fiordland this very shadowy
sort of Lord of the Rings place and
diving in the temperate water there and
I was photographing macro life on the
wall there's colorful little tiny
animals and I looked up and in the
distance saw this sevengill shark a very
prehistoric looking animal sort of
coming at me so I I swapped my macro rig
for a wide-angle that my assistant was
holding and was able to make a single
frame but again the correlation is
between healthy shark populations and
healthy oceans it's it's a direct
correlation and that's what I've learned
so whenever possible and want to make
images that sort of speak to that that
relationship and it was the same
everywhere I went you know you'd go to
places that were saw dead coral reefs
and in parts of the Caribbean let's say
and you just didn't see many sharks or I
went to the Bahamas with places in the
Bahamas where the reefs were were pretty
healthy and there were lots of sharks
around so you could see it it was quite
evident and in in my work as it evolved
I also wanted particularly in the
stories for National Geographic I wanted
to try to show readers a little bit more
of the lives of sharks a little bit more
the life cycle you know particularly
focusing for a period of time on on baby
sharks on shark pups because at the time
I made this photo of a lemon shark pup
in Bimini in the Bahamas
and hadn't really seen a lot of images
of this kind of thing but it's in in
very it's a very important part of the
equation you know most folks just want
to look at the big scary sharks or the
jaws and the teeth and the blood and
that kind of thing but you know this is
an important part of the equation lemon
shark pups have their babies in mangrove
nurseries and these very shallow places
where trees grow out of the water and
it's a place where big predators
get in and the lemon sharks live for the
first two to three years of their lives
in these nurseries where they feed and
eventually get big enough to go out and
compete on the reef but this was a
fairly new born lemon shark pup that was
maybe only 12 inches in length swimming
in about a foot deep of water I spent
days laying in that mangrove trying to
get the Sharks to build up their courage
and come close and after I left this
place I learned that some of these
mangroves had been bulldozed so that a
golf course could be made for a resort
and this is the only shark nursery for
150 miles around and critical habitat so
these are vital so having images like
this within the context of a story I
think helps people to understand the
importance of protecting places like
this and whenever possible I also wanted
to show behavior with sharks it's a
little hard to do sometimes but while
working on a story about the
Mesoamerican Reef that is the second
largest Barrier Reef in the world I was
able to photograph Caribbean reef sharks
predating on lionfish now as you may
know lionfish are invasive species in in
the Atlantic Ocean they've sort of just
exploded and there haven't really been
any great solutions to eradicating them
there's some places where divers will go
down and and try to spear them and it's
had some low-level impact but in Roatan
and Honduras there was a shark biologist
that over a couple years had been trying
to train the local Caribbean reef sharks
to acquire a taste for these he had
initially spear them and and feed them
to them and over time they began to
naturally predate on them and it was
controlling the population they were
beginning to to go down and naturally
per day Don that so that was important
too but at the end of the day I mostly
really hope that by showing sharks as
something beautiful as just beautiful
animals you know making pictures that
would intrigue the reader and making
them want to know more might dispel some
of that fear again that shadowy you know
looking at pictures like koppel teeth
copy that you know just make them look
like monsters isn't gonna help anything
but if we can show these animals is more
beautiful I mean maybe not quite
dolphins but but certainly something to
to marvel at and while working on a
story about sharks of the Bahamas a few
years for the magazine I spent 18 days
in wintertime in the Bahamas trying to
get a photo of the elusive great
hammerhead that we see here but the
because of the rough weather that we had
at that time of year I only had two days
where I could actually work and I made
this frame on the very last night at
sunset when this big 14-foot male should
have just swirled in just below the
surface but you know the idea was that
my hope is that a photo like this might
engage people or readers in the magazine
they want to read the caption and
hopefully the story and learn that
camera had populations in the last 20
years or so in the in the Atlantic Ocean
have declined about 89 percent these are
animals that we don't know very much
about we don't know where they travel to
or from necessarily we don't know where
they mate we don't know where they have
their pups and we're losing them faster
than we can learn about them so to be
able to make beautiful pictures or
engaging images of sharks I think is a
big part of it the fact is almost every
species of shark out there in the world
is in real trouble certainly all the
predatory species and they really do
need our help
so as my career evolved I wanted to turn
my camera to its some of the darker side
of what was happening to sharks as well
because I felt it was necessary to show
people what was happening to these
animals and the global slaughter that
was occurring around the world a lot of
sharks are killed for food but the truth
is this is wildlife and every single
year right now on planet earth more than
a hundred million sharks are being
killed I mean think about that number a
hundred million sharks we can't kill a
hundred million apex predators and
expect any ecosystem to be healthy and
that's certainly the case here so as I
worked on these kinds of stories I sort
of got away from trying to make you know
beautiful pictures and approached it
more like war photography I wanted to
make images that would would grab
people's attention so it was dead sharks
being cut up on a beach or a dead mako
shark in a gill net and showing another
mako here on the beach being fin you
know most of those sharks the hundred
million or whatever the actual number is
maybe more than 100 million most of
those are killed for their fins for the
soup fin business and the shark fin soup
that's very popular in Asia and that's
what's happening here they fetch a very
high price so that's the first thing
that the fisherman goes for and as I was
working on this story I I wanted it was
a story about the global fish crisis the
problems
of overfishing and shark fishing was a
big component of that I really wanted an
image that would create some empathy for
these animals I think you know this
picture might have done it but it was
actually one morning when I jumped in
the water in the Sea of Cortez came
along uh a gill net where this thresher
shark had just recently died and it's I
was still open and because it's a
pelagic animal that had these great big
pectoral fins like we saw on the blue
shark earlier and you know as I framed
it up in my camera's viewfinder it sort
of struck me as a crucifixion and I
thought that maybe that would give some
empathy to these animals that that
really are in trouble and need our help
it became the lead picture in that cover
story in 2007 but it's gone on to have a
life beyond that being used by a number
of conservation organizations as well to
sort of beat that drum and help people
understand the plight of sharks so all
of this sort of preload brings me to the
work that I recently did for National
Geographic these series of four stories
about some of the top predatory species
of sharks as Greg mentioned we ran three
of them this summer in June July and
August and we have one story yet to be
published a story on mako sharks that
that will be upcoming and you know I
think my hope was that by doing that as
I mentioned earlier consecutively
readers would would come to see these
animals as different as to some degree
having personality and as being
something that we can not only respect
but but really marvel at you know I I
don't have any illusions that the sharks
or fish which is what they are of course
will ever be held in the same regard
that a furry mammal you know I think we
have a natural affinity to terrestrial
animals particularly cute animals that
live in the forest but I do think that
if we can we can show these animals as
miracles of evolution then maybe we can
get some respect and if we get the
respect than appreciation and move that
dial a little bit in terms of
conservation